today we'll talk about some positional
what it's like to play a positional game
and this game is against a very strong
world-class player that I play
Grandmaster Hyun Elvis he was as far as
I think fourth or fifth highest rated
player in the world at one time so very
strong player and I managed to win this
game in a very positional style and you
will see and I will be asking you to
find some of the moves so d4 d6 I'm
playing with a white pieces okay so he
played the six and since he knows I'm
not a efore player so I probably won't
play this move and I went Knight f3 and
have five who can tell me why is he
playing a Dutch defense via this move
order what is he trying to avoid by
playing via d6 d4 aha if you remember I
show the game before when opponent plays
f5 the Dutch defense I normally go 93 e4
and this is very very aggressive way to
play to fight for the e4 square in the
Dutch defence by playing d6 9 f3 he got
to the f5 now no longer 93 4 will work
because if I go 93 he simply goes Knight
f6 and he is controlling the square so I
cannot get what I normally play against
- defense
so by this tricky move order he
basically and stopped me from playing my
usual setup against the Dutch defense
but again I can also play the classical
set up against Dutch which I did in this
game so I decided to play now c4
g6g 390 f6 Bishop g2 this is the most
popular way to play against the batch
and here I play the interesting move
here know what most popular is 93 again
you can play d5 but I didn't play those
moves
can you find the next move I played in
this game my plan is just to develop my
pieces solidly bring my rooks into the
game and try to play a four in some
point this is my ultimate goal here
after the development I want to play E 4
and open up the file well if you go
Bishop g5 not so effective because he
just comes in 94 and he is putting
pressure ok
okay
so that's why what can you do here to
just get your development
93 this will be the typical setup you
know one of the main ideas black is
trying to do is to play e5 here and
oftentimes what they do is they play c6
Queen e8 and they play e5 so I need you
to find a plan that will prevent that
that you will have some more control of
the e5 square so he cannot just play
that that idea but correct that's what I
play d3 because you see when you put a
[ __ ] poem before that's like you're
putting your piece not on a very good
square but yes you're trying to start
but it's not a very good square for the
bishop because right now it's biting
here on the this chain that it's not
very it's not going to do anything to me
so that's why I play b3 here okay
because I want to go B should be too
so he played c6 Bishop b2 and now he
plays a5 trying to gain some space here
have a question for you where you think
I should develop my nightmare I have few
options I can go to c3 and d2 which
square is the best d2 right since you
already did at the end if you can check
off your bishop you don't want to put a
knight here to block it okay that's why
you want to put it on d2 to make sure
you have more control on d5 square
because now you got one two and three
right you got three pieces that
controlling so it's you know it's going
to take some time for him to be able to
play e5 because you got that under
control
okay so you really got that under
control now
after I played 1982 equals nine a six it
looks a little bit strange but this is
you know they play like this this is
playable so the idea is to go night
before in some point to attack the Queen
and also ninety seven is a possibility
now which accurate move you need to play
here first because my ideal setup here
is to go Queen c2 and then rookie wanna
try to play 44 this is what I like to do
a three correct you take time to play a
three first because you want to control
the before square okay now he goes
Bishop d7 developing Queen City right
following it up developing now the major
pieces if you can see probably that I'm
just following the very important five
steps in this game controlling the
center developing my minor pieces first
castle now developing the major pieces
before trying to do anything aggressive
okay so it's very important that you got
also in your games to follow the steps
now he plays c5 he is attacking my
center and now how should I try to react
to this move I can try to push I can
take or maybe I can do also something
else so but what do you think is the
best way to react to c5 move here
and what's the idea behind a tree and
look at the e-file now I can simply even
double up my rooks on e-file and then I
have a very nice pressure so that's fine
by playing d5 you already commit and at
this point at the early stage of the
game I didn't want to commit yet and
this is something you should try to do
also when you push the pawn you already
commit that you know you can't go back
anymore by playing only three I could
still play d5 but I keep the tension
because taking it not good for him
because I take a NAPA to my rooks on
open file so I want to keep the tension
here that's why I play e3 now he goes
Queen c7
now what do you do now
which piece you want to develop which
rook specify a rook everyone correct
I went rook everyone he goes rook a e8
and as soon as he plays this move he has
a threat actually it's not a threat of
winning a piece or anything but it's a
strong positional threat and I had to do
something so let me let me know if you
see the threat here first what is black
trying to do after the move rook a e8
why did he play this move exactly he
wants to play e5 and now he has enough
control on d5 square for example if I
would play the natural move natural
looking move he would push a 5 and takes
he can take and now yes I can take only
5 but then I lose 2 pieces for a rock
and in this type of positions it's
better to have more pieces than rook
because it's not an endgame where your
rook is going to be more active so lots
of pieces on the board so I cannot
really take and if I don't take he
pushes efore attacking my knight okay so
that's why I don't want to allow him to
play e5 now after rook a e8
so what can I do to prevent that now
absolutely now d5c that's why I didn't
commit early now I can play this multi
five because I already see kind of what
is he trying to do he's trying to you
know play on a knee file so I play d5
and now he plays a four the point is if
I take is just going to go Queen 85 and
then it's going to pick up the pawn back
and now my structure is little bit loose
and I'm losing time it's kind of
deflecting me from the main my main idea
and what is my main idea in this opening
after I set up my pieces like this yes
correct yes I'm trying to play a four
here because after a four yeah you never
want to put the root behind a pond like
this and leave it there because it's
just not effective so my idea is to play
E 4 and this position I don't want to
waste time on taking that's why I simply
went for it right away okay efore he
takes
that's let's think first let's think for
a few minutes okay because we don't want
to rush we can take right away we have
some other moves you know but we want to
think in a positions like this it's very
important moment here so we want to make
sure we don't rush so you have two
options here that you need to consider
why do you prefer ninety five overnight
xe4 haha it's very good this is actually
a very typical move when opponent takes
it's not like you have to take right
away you actually move the night and
then now you have a choice of which
piece with which piece you want to
capture you can capture with an ID you
can capture with this so you have many
ways to capture so that's why you go
ninety five here it's more precise now
you go squeen be six
activating his queen and putting
pressure you know now I cannot take with
this night because it takes on v3 so
what would be the best move here for
white
yes he does have some pressure here
that's one idea see he wants to make me
take with uncomfortable way to spawn
it's lots of settle to sear it so he's
trying to you know complicate the
position here but here you can actually
avoid all that by playing a precise move
one precise movement you just avoid all
that
keep the h1
the problem is he always wants to take
well but then Knight g4 jumps in and
tricky
before you can't he takes and also this
f2 is going to be hanging it's a
difficult move to find I think because
you don't think that he takes you know
because I don't want to go to endgame
and if I don't want to take back with
him night because he's going to go
Bishop a4 so I'm kind of you know very
good that's a good way of thinking
because he already moved the Queen once
now I can solve all the problems all
this pressure by just taking it okay by
just taking it but but earlier his Queen
earlier but he moved now it's a
different position we were trying to
avoid that earlier but you know position
changes an evaluation and what you need
to do it changes as well
so what you were trying to avoid few
moves before might be okay for you to do
now now I took and then now I can just
simply recapture so he goes III gives up
the pawn he knows he's going to lose it
so he gives it up
I take rook takes c3 and now he goes
Bishop takes a four little tactic that
he's trying to do yeah and I don't want
to lose the bishop on v2 because now you
know his queen is going to get very
active
I can't just take care because he takes
my bishop and now his queen is very
active so
don't want to begin under the pillow
don't don't put the knight and pin
yourself okay
so don't want to do that so you have
something better here
you need a calm move here yes he did
some tactic it doesn't mean like we have
to panic because he just had this idea
we just need to play to find a solid
move and we still have pressure in fact
be file it's something I can use also in
the future because you know I can get
through be one with the temple question
is where C 1 because C 3 will run into
trouble who can see the trouble discover
attack VI tribe though because other
discover attacks will lead to checkmate
on g7 so you need to go to h5 and now
only Knight and trap will work no other
discover attacks okay so that's why we
go Knight h5 so Quincy won now he goes
97 I think we should try to get all our
pieces developed ok and we have a piece
right now that is not well developed so
you bring that piece into the game see
one more temple because he needs to move
the Queen so we get the rook into the
game with the tempo it's always nice
when you can do that now we have all the
pieces developed here so now we need to
find some moves to improve the position
that's a very interesting move I could
have played that move that's very
interesting but here if you look at the
position
besides the bishop bishop a tree is
interesting move there is another piece
that I can try to improve here which
piece is that well think a little bit
think see I spent some time here I mean
because it's important to see where is
the weakness and how we can try to put
more pressure on the weakness yes
possible but if you look at the position
here whose knight is more active my
knight on g5 or his knight on c7 okay
so you don't want to change your active
piece unless you really have to okay
because it's you want to go ninety six
but you have to see how his night is
just defending so let him at least play
h6 you know we can the position and
maybe then we can do that correct Queen
e1 queen is not doing anything here so
you go here and you now pressure here
and now he plays h6 see he's weakening
his position because you know who wants
to play again where his opponent Knight
is here threatening and controlling so
now he goes question is what do we do
here you have a choice but you need to
make the right decision here because you
can lose your advantage if you make the
wrong decision
I can go to e6 what are the candidates
moves here 96 9 24 9 12 3 9 12 trees to
passive we probably don't want to do
that so you need to choose between 96
and 94 how do you determine like in this
position how would you determine which
move to make here what will be your
thinking process here okay but it's
night on c7 a good piece the most
important is night on c7 is the good
piece but you're not applying to take
with the pawn are you but then what
about the backward pawn no more backward
pawn not sure how are you going to win a
pawn it goes Bishop c6 back and look at
that he will exchange your bishop now
and some jump in with 94 coming up -
okay don't wanna you know see Julian
this would be a typical this is an error
because look you got two pieces on open
file say my open file yeah if you take
like this you immediately deactivate
this pieces okay so it's why it's a
nuance you know but you have to realize
in a game not to do that because now
your whole idea of doubling up here and
putting pressure is gone you might need
to find a way to now relocate these
pieces because they're not going to be
effective here and this pawn is it's a
good one but then it'll be tricky an
endgame because his King is very close
to it can simply come up and take it so
some of the Indians we have to be a
little bit extra careful because you
could just simply come up and take it
that's something upon endgame King g7
king of six the move is Knight g4
because let's leave the bad piece there
okay let's try to exchange this because
at this point I'm aiming for attack I'm
aiming for attack here that's why I want
to leave this piece here on the Queen
side
and exchange the one on the kingside so
I can try to attack him
9g for white is slightly better here
it's nothing huge here slightly better
Bishop d7 plate and how do we proceed
now what should be the next one here for
white
he played Bishop d7
yes absolutely absolutely because I want
his King not to have so many defenders I
want to change this night I want to
change this nun not this not this night
you know let him be there for now take
the night correct now he doesn't want to
take with a bishop because then his King
is going to be really alone so he takes
to the pawn now it seems like we cannot
move the title from d2 because we are
too tied up to the c-4 weakness it seems
like we know because we really want to
play 94 but then the c4 pawn is weak
it's possible but then he exchanges the
rooks he goes through ki8 and almost
nothing left for my advantage
next one is absolutely necessary because
if he takes only three goes rook e8 he
has lots of pressure
not if you find the next move find the
next move you have more pressure on his
position clean up we're here the thing
is he's also wants to play he also wants
to play b5 so it's not like he's just
sitting there for the defense he wants
to play b5 clean up the problem as he
takes and see he's he's liquidating and
now he's getting the file and I don't
want liquidations here and you know
giving them the e-file can you use your
tactics here can you use your tactics to
accomplish would win white needs here
rookie 7 the problem is the smooth
doesn't threaten anything it's a nice
move but it has a what is your threat
you can't take my bishop you lose your
queen so
I did this more in later on in the game
a little bit later
it does look but yeah if it takes it
that might be good for you yeah so what
do you do here huh
which piece we can try to improve in
this possession GTO bishop earbud we can
go to h3 and Bishop f1 is too difficult
my main problem is he wants to take what
can you do to stop this exchanger f5
perhaps losing temples here losing
temples for one go here but then we lose
tempos remember chess it's all about
temples how about a tactic layer what
can you do to stop rook takes e3
okay but yeah we could but you that's
how good yeah he gets the file and it's
no advantage here
calculate three moves three four moves
here you will realize that this
particular move works
see you never want to get to the point
in your game where you're not sure what
to do and you just make a move yeah like
you add you always even if it's
difficult you don't want to just make a
move okay like you don't just close your
eyes and make a move because that will
be maybe a blunder unless you're running
out of time then you have to move yes
well complete one isn't doing a whole
lot right now but the problem is he
takes our rook see you could do that but
the problem is he takes the rook you
take and then he has the file and not so
clear why we are so much better here we
might not be better I don't want to
change the rooks
ha ha we're really calculating
well but let's see what you need to
calculate here is he takes the pawn
right then you take rook takes yeah but
now you don't have to cool really deep
here because look at this night this
night is very active here so you just
take back now look at this it's got this
pawn is saying in this pawn is hanging
and this Queen is hanging a lot of
things hanging for him and position is
open now and your bishops going to be
very powerful okay it's an open board
yeah Knight takes pawn here well
okay so you can just take now this is
very important 94 now he plays b5
because he wants to get rid of his
weakness and try to create some contra
play
I took he plays Bishop b5 now you need
to find another plant here now you need
to regroup your pieces here okay like
there is a piece for in particular the
rook on b1 it's not doing much so can
you regroup your pieces here and because
that way you will be more active and you
will have some more threats in the
future and by the way the d5 pawn is
hanging
yes
but I want to have a roof defending just
a pawn you know I mean and then I'm I'm
not very strong money file I would like
to get my rooks on a file to be honest
because then I can when I move my knight
I can threaten some entry you know like
rookie seven ideas like that
well push-ups if fun can hit they take
this one you might might take that one
nuts okay but no Bishop is fine here yes
I want to move my queen
exactly I want to move my Queen d2
perfect Queen goes to D to protecting
the pawn good now he goes rook b8 and
now he wants to perhaps move the bishop
and attack so now I will need to bring
my rook to e1 right rook ve 198 he is
defending the position he is holding
Iran in a positions like this where you
feel like you've kind of improved your
pieces but there is no way to break
through what do you do what's the how do
you create some weaknesses around
opponent's king what idea use well we
are not at the point where we going to
be looking for sacrifices at this point
we still to early is early this is the
early stage of the attack pawn sounds
good but not break pawn push here
because in a position like this when
opponent King side pass I'll lose this
fans are loose right so what can you do
to create some more holes that you can
enter later on with your pieces here
what's the typical way to attack this
position h4 of course h4
threatening to play h5 do you use this
kind of ideas in your games say some
people like to use this in every game
every game they push h4 regardless of
you need to do it or you don't need to
do it but here it's a necessity because
we weaken the position okay
h4 he goes Bishop d7 now his bishop
retreated and now I would like to
improve my light-square bishop
and I can do that with the tempo attack
the Queen now he goes here attacking my
bishop where do you want to put this
bishop you could go to a one but can you
put it on a more active square instead
of course so you have some more options
right on a one you just in a corner not
doing too much here we have some other
ideas Bishop c3 now he goes rook e8
attacking my weakness on a3 now we
defend it
Quincy one rook f7 now this is a little
difficult game a little bit maybe to
understand but it's lots of maneuvering
going on here
you know I'm trying to outmaneuver him
he's trying to improve his position
white is much better in this position
because his King putts ID is going to be
weak now but now this next move
it's very important there is a piece you
have here that it looks very good but
you can actually improve this piece to a
better square and this will give you
chances to activate your other pieces
which piece I'm talking about the
night-night it is a very nice looking
piece here but unfortunately he is
attacking but opponent is defending and
this Knight is preventing us from
activating our rooks so we need to
improve the position of this piece where
absolutely and in a structure like this
remember a structure like this if you
can get the knight on c4 it's always
good because you put pressure on the
weakness okay and your knight cannot be
chased around it's like an outpost
cannot be chased around with the pawn
Knight DQ at this point my opponent was
getting more and more uncomfortable so
you are spending more time and got into
time trouble 9 c4 comes in f5 and now
you know he realize h5 is coming Bishop
d3 is coming see this was a very
important maneuver yeah to weaken his
position so he said okay I have to try
to exchange the bishops at least to get
something going absolutely rook d7
correct nagas bishop f8 trying to
exchange my roof and now let's see if
you can find the best move in this
position
I really like this move this is a
favorite move my favorite move in this
game
it feels like his king is so loose here
I should be able to do something to take
advantage of the weaknesses around his
King but it's not so easy
h5 well but the problem is he just went
here and he's attacking me so I have to
do something with the rook first I have
to do something with the rook but I
can't just push it
rook 7e six correct so this is an idea
I've learned I studied a lot of
Petrossian games and he in his
masterpiece games he used this kind of
ideas where he puts the exchange but
when up opponent captures then his
pieces are entering in so it's a very
important idea rookie six and now I'm
attacking the weakness so he took now
how are you going to capture back here
with the pawn or with the rook what do
you think rook now what Pontic is also
it's interesting white is still better
after thinking with the pawn but of
course I take with rook because I go for
that Turkish now you will see how useful
was to play h4 move earlier because when
he plays now h7 what do you do to weaken
his position more now see if your palm
was on h2 you couldn't break through but
thanks to the h5 now I'm breaking
through his position now threatening to
take on g6 he is forced to react taking
looks very bad so he plays g5 now why
did we bring the bishop on f1 see all
the moves for white is connected because
I was expecting something like this may
occur so now I bring this piece into the
game Bishop d3 he is up in exchange but
his pieces are extremely passive now I'm
threatening simply
to play g4 and pick up on f5
it's not like I'm winning immediately
but it's it's coming there so g4 is
threatening now he goes Bishop g7 what
do you do push the pawn now he is afraid
his king is here so he goes back here
take back with the bishop now all my
disks are extremely active my knight my
rook my bishop and now I'm threatening
to play bishop g6 attacking the rook the
knight you can do much so he decided to
sacrifice the exchanges to take away the
strong Bishop rook takes f5 this was by
the way in the 48th move so he just made
time control he was in trying trouble
too so I took back with a pawn and now
he goes Queen f7 looks kind of
threatening he wants to pick up the
pawns
now
what do you do here
well left six he could take
probably with the knife okay but not
some queen h5 jumps in I don't want to
allow any contra play yes we could do
that but could we pin the piece first
could we pin him huh could we pin him
now we want to threaten f6 now it's just
winning so he has to take correct now he
wants to go queen g4 so what do you do
first to stop that with the temple 93
now he has to go back win d7 and who can
find a move after which he resigned it
may look like a premature resignation
but in fact he just saw that two three
moves later he's going to get checkmated
so that's why he resigned
now when you have a pressure like this
you don't want to release the pressure
Queen B 2 is a move that you resign
after my treat is here to take on g7 he
takes I go night f5 so let's say he goes
here
I take he takes Knight f5 we will get I
think I know what you can ask here now
checkmate
ok so he can't do that so now the
question is probably what to do after
this right he didn't play this move you
resigned because this is losing who can
find a line winning the line here who
can find a winning line here
you know 9f5 quintics
rugby seven
we made is a possibility we have a ruby
7 editor there is a very nice finish in
one of the lines there
can you exchange the bishops that forces
correct you got the first move
where is the follow-up though now he can
he'll play two moves King here or here
this loses because we just take his
pinned if he goes here what do you do
a fire expert quit a quick check quickly
cook I think if I tell you what you need
to do you'll find it quickly well you
could take the pawn probably win don't
think I should just think yes ting can
you do something spectacular very good
again you what's the follow-up see this
scenario checkmate
excellent so you can go here now so he
has to go here and now what do you do
what do you do don't rush well why you
want to play 95 can I just take it okay
you probably win weekend g8 yeah but
better
yes better queen bee - actually I go
back to g8 at the same position you get
behind it okay the weather you get
behind it this is a very important idea
yeah your look is in now get the route
Queen behind it because now he can
protect properly
he takes checkmate check okay well my
black just takes so it leads to a
checkmate as you can see okay so that's
why after Queen B - he resigned here
because he can't do anything
so it's a very positional game where
lots of maneuvering took place here okay
but the fact that my King was safe and
his scheme was weaker this was very
important so now I want to go back again
to the moment where I played h4 when
you're in a position like this where
opponent King is bit loose the structure
so you want to try think of this idea h4
h5 especially if he has played already
h6 move or F move because then if your
power reaches when I Drive it will be
very strong okay because then if it
takes its weak and if he pushes g5 it's
quick okay so remember the side the edge
fold now Bishop is not very good on g2
so we improve it with the temple to
bring the bishop because it was under
attack defending the weakness and now
transfer the knight to civil once my
knight was on c4 I felt like I'm close
to close to be winning now because now
Bishop d3 is coming up - you can see all
my piece is now aiming towards the skink
and where is this counter play no contra
player that's the most important thing
if you can get a position like this
where the opponent doesn't have a contra
play then it's very difficult to play
you might not have a very big advantage
but the fact that the opponent doesn't
know what to do
it's extremely difficult to sit on a
position and just go back and forth even
very strong grandmasters they eventually
they just push something and they just
maybe lose even quicker so it's very
very difficult even in end games just to
sit there and just do nothing
okay so again f5 and very important
sequence here is rupees six when you
have played this kind of moving the game
sacrificing an exchange so very very
famous games Braunstein panthro's and
there are many games play like a team
like this where he sacrifice the
exchange but you get a very important
square for your piece okay good question
because in this position is Bishop is on
a faith if I go right away this Bishop
is on g3 he has a chance to exchange the
bishops and when I go here I force them
to go back first and then I go here in a
lot of the lines I take on g6 with the
check yeah and I keep my bishop because
I have only have more force to attack
him right so I want to keep the bishop
that's the idea okay okay so again lots
of maneuvering and improving the pieces
and when you play games and you don't
see a good plan try to see if all your
pieces placed on the good squares and
look for yeah and always we use this h4
h5 against the fianchetto structure okay
always use h4 h5 okay any questions
about this game this is 2010 2010 okay
now I want to set up one position and
want to discuss this position okay let's
is played by Kasparov why to play and
this is team you know how to play on
open files okay
this is a cast part of game from long
time ago in 1977 against Grand Master P
Gustav
so how did white breakthrough in this
position
wrote the I want you to think for a few
minutes at least yeah this is I don't
want to just call out a move yeah I want
you if you call out a move you just want
to make sure you have some follow-up to
it too you don't want to just make a
move
obviously white is down upon but his
pieces are very active Queen Bishop
rooks so you have lots of pieces you can
attack with but you need to find that
first move and see the follow up that
you have okay after that so so what's
the first move rook f6 okay now he
cannot take because a Queen takes pawn
checkmate okay so you cannot take now
after this move he can play Knight f8
for example and looks like he is
defending his King
what can you do now for white to be able
to win this game in three moves
better
seven might be winning you have
something better cook better excellent
check because he can't go here you take
and say checkmate so he has to take no
choice then we check because we force
him to take and then we go checkmate
King is alone and when opponent King is
alone you look for that sacrifice to be
able to break through through the
defense so he played Knight g5 his
opponent now what do you do now this
looks like he's blocking now this attack
and now he just wants to take this
rook takes night now he has two options
take with h1 which he did in the game or
take with this pawn if it takes with
this pawn what do you do well your queen
is only 3 h5 threatened queen h6 and
mate so he has to go here
now we take 1 check now it was here
think you don't want to just go check
here you want to think because he wants
to go Queen g7 yeah you can probably win
by taking politics pawn here too but
what will be the best move here to
actually checkmate to set up the
checkmate
well that's the best move now that's the
best move nothing wrong with it
now you check that's the point he cannot
go Queen g7 anymore the king is in a
mating net okay
so let's look at what happened in the
game so he took this one this rope now
what's the follow-up now Queen takes
pawn he cannot take with the pawn
because of check check mate okay so you
can take that
so after Queen g5 he played the only
move King g8 now
Oh
well you're pinned you'll quit your rock
is pinned and now looks like he may have
survived the strong attack Queen h4 it's
better this way to keep the so now
you're threatening to go Queen eight
seven so now he goes Queen 83 now what
do you do after Queen 80 because he
wants to attack your Bishop too
he couldn't take because then it's the
same checkmate right check goes here his
King his Queen he's actually blocking so
he cannot escape okay so that's why he
goes Queen a3 and now after which move
you're winning after which move rook
excellent quiet move see at then you
make a quiet move now because you're
threatening Bishop eight seven check
that wins his Queen and also you
threaten the queen h7 and Queen h8
thread which is winning the rock
okay so rook f3 there is no good defense
against two threads so he pulls g6
continual Bishop takes g6 discover the
attack on the Queen he takes your piece
better correct King f8 and then politics
in this case he cannot capture because
we take the rook or go Queen H a check
but he cannot even go check from here
okay so that's why he resigned after gtx
f3 and Kasparov won okay
so this is how you attack when you have
active pieces and open lines okay so
this is an example by world champion
Kasparov